many people working in the healthcare
sector chose their profession because
they were interested in health
obviously health is unbelievably
important but an enormous driver of
what's happening in the sector now is
economics
in order to understand fully the forces
that are shaping the evolution of the
health care sector you need to
understand the underlying economic
drivers that affect patients providers
and payers
all leaders whether they be on the
purchasing side or on the provider side
or even working with patients need to
understand those forces so they can
anticipate the challenges that they will
face and structure their activities to
meet those challenges
you'll explore healthcare spending
growth
consider how new technologies and
services lead to higher spending
and examine how changes to benefit
design and payment reform can promote a
fiscally sustainable health system that
delivers high quality care we need to
decide what kind of care should be
provided and not just leave it up to a
system that's broken that helps escalate
these costs primary care is the long
game it's not about sort of dumping
everything out in one 20-minute visit
we'll use conversations with industry
experts real-world examples and
interactive lessons to help you create
more effective growth strategies better
negotiate reimbursements and
partnerships and become an advocate for
healthcare economics both inside and
outside of your organization come
explore the economic forces shaping
healthcare
[Music]